Hi, I’m Adriene Hill and Welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics.
In this series we’ve been talking a lot
about how often you see data and statistics
on the news and on social media.
There are all sorts of studies and data sets
promising the keys to a better life.
Coffee is good for you. No wait.
It’s killing you So what do you trust?
INTRO
Journalism has many goals to inform, expose,
help people make better decisions about their
communities and their lives.
But, the only way journalism matters--is if
people read it or watch it or listen to it.
Journalists have to capture the attention
of their audience and help them connect with
the story.
Case studies and observational studies can
be great source materials for articles or
podcast.
But, it’s always important to look at both
the quality of the science.
And the quality of the journalism.
If there’s a study without a control group
or with non-randomized design it’s going
to be less reliable.
And if a journalist doesn’t ask those questions,
or just doesn’t include the answers in her
story, how are you going to know?
Back in 2015, newspapers around the world
ran stories heralding Chocolate as a way to
lose weight.
It sounded great.
But turns out it wasn’t good journalism
or good science.
A science journalist and PhD named John Bohannon
created this story by doing a real, randomized
study, but one that was intentionally riddled
with flaws.
It was meant to be a way to show that academic
journals would publish the very flawed study.
And so would news outlets.
The goal, writes Bohannon, was to demonstrate how easy it is to turn bad science into big headlines.
And it worked.
Once the study was published and the press
release went out journalists jumped on it.
Bohannon says that many outlets ran the story
without ever contacting him.
Very few reporters asked about the number
of subjects they tested-- only 16--and no
he says, reported that number.
Also says Bohannon the stories that ran didn’t quote any outside researchers for corroboration.
And while it is disappointing that you can’t
add some Cadbury to your diet and lose weight,
and maybe your aunt keeps quoting this study
to you as she downs that 5th and 6th bon-bon,
but bad science and bad scientific journalism
is not always that harmless.
Most clinical studies base their conclusions
on statistical tests that give researchers--and
the rest of us a quantifiable way to measure
the evidence that the study provides.
For example, when a reputable doctor claims
that Ibuprofen increases the risk of fertility
issues in men, it’s because there was a
study with a group that took Ibuprofen and
a control group that didn’t, and the subjects
taking Ibuprofen showed a tangible increase
in some measure of infertility.
But which measure?
And was the control group given a placebo?
An article that you see on Yahoo health, probably
won’t tell you in fact this one doesn’t.
For that information, you have to go to the
original academic article, and those can be
kinda dense.
It turns out that this study did have a placebo
control group, and it measured infertility
in a clinically respectable way, by measuring
levels of fertility related hormones.
But these facts are important when considering
how trustworthy the conclusion of a study
is, and a lot of news articles don’t have them.
As a side note if this study was done in rats
instead of humans the conclusion that Ibuprofen
increases the risk of fertility issues in
men would not be as strongly supported!
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
Imagine that you’re going about your morning
as usual, sipping your coffee and scrolling
through the latest news when you see an article with the title “Miracle Food causes weight loss!"
You want to fit better into your jeans so,
you click through.
You see that the miracle food is called Targ,
AND the results were “statistically significant”so
it’ seems legit.
You jump in your car and drive down to the
local grocery store and see that Targ is on
sale!
So you pick up the largest pack and start
eating you’re already feeling stronger
But then you begin to experience side effects
like heartburn and stomach ulcers and a desire
to fight.
The article you read didn’t mention that
when researchers considered the over 20,000
subjects that the weight loss was only about
1/10th of a pound more for Targ eaters.
That’s not very much maybe not worth these side effects.
When a study reports something as significant,
you probably assume that this means that it’s
really gonna matter, but this isn’t always
the case, since significant means something
different in statistics than in everyday English.
And Science journalists can misuse this confusion
by not mentioning how big of an effect was
observed.
Thanks Thought Bubble!
We don’t have time to read all the academic
articles on even one topic that affects us.
Take what gets called “text neck”-- a
condition that includes sore neck muscles
from looking down at your phone and laptop
all the time.
A Google Scholar search for Academic articles
about “Text Neck” returns over 180 results
and that’s only since 2013.
There’s no way that you could read all of
those without exacerbating your already sore neck.
So we need people like scientific journalists
who can distill all those articles into digestible--and
engaging--pieces for us to consume.
It’s helpful to be skeptical but we should
keep reading about science.
When reading a science story it’s important
to note a couple things: who wrote it, who
published it, who did the science, and who
funded the science.
If an article that tells you that drinking
Diet Coke is good for your teeth and is on
the Coke website, your suspicion should be
raised more so than if it was published by
Scientific American.
You should also consider who funded and completed
the research the article is based on.
If you read an article that claims a rare
fruit juice will reduce your blood pressure
and stave of cancer and you see that study
was funded by the juice company.
Be suspicious.
Not every study funded by a company is inherently
flawed.
Science cost money, it can be expensive, and while there are sources of funding from governments and other neutral
organizations, the reality is that often the
people who are willing to pay to have the
research done are the companies who have a
vested interest in the results.
Sometimes to get the research done, researchers
need to partner with these organization.
Privately funded research can be done well.
Another thing to watch for in science and
health journalism is whether the claims made
in the headline actually match the claims
made in the story.
You don’t see many stories with headlines
like “Ketchup may have mild relationship
with weight gain in men over 40”cause who’s
going to read that?
It might be accurate, but it’s just not
as flashy as “Is Ketchup making you fat!?”
There are a number of reasons we get this
splashy headlines.Media outlets from Buzzfeed
to Goop to the old-guard newspapers are all
fighting for audience these days--Maybe not
exactly the same audience but audience.
And that competition makes the super-sexy
headline, really, really appealing.
Sensational gets clicks.
Content creators are under pressure to find
and write what’s gonna get shared.
The language of correlation is uncertain and,
as such, less catchy.
You’ll also spot plenty of causation problems
in science and health reporting.
When you see an article that claims that “doing
yoga cures cancer” you should check to see
whether it was an experimental study or whether
the claim is based on correlation on a survey
between doing yoga and not having cancer.
Only experimental studies with randomized
designs and control groups have a shot at
showing evidence of causation.
Because personally, I can think of a lot of
confounding factors for yoga and cancer study.
Nowon to another way science can get mischaracterized.
There are studies done on mice and rats that
get reported as if they were studies on humans.
And while a lot of medical and health related
studies get their start in mouse models many
of the treatments that work in mice don’t
end up being successful in their human counterparts.
Similarly, you will see clickbait-y headlines
that say “Hydrogen Peroxide kills cancer!”
and lists all the ways you can now incorporate
H2O2 into your daily life.
But what the title doesn’t tell you is that
these were in vitro studies, which means they’re
done on real cancer cells but in a petri dish.
In a very simplified sense-- the cells were
grown by themselves in a dish and the substance
of interest was put into the dish and it killed
the cancer cells.
But in a dish lots of things we consume everyday
will kill cancer cells like coffee, or alcohol.
But they even working in tandem aren’t going
to cure cancer.
Anyway these misguided “hydrogen peroxide
kills cancer” headlines get shared around
online and people come up with alternative
therapies that involve consuming Hydrogen
Peroxide which can be really, really dangerous.
Like dead dangerous.
Science stories can make for great journalism.
And they can give you something clever to
say at your next dinner party.
But any time you hear a cable talk show host
says the phrase “scientists have found...”
or “a new study suggests…” you should
always just look up that study to be sure.
At least before you start spreading it around.
And if the results of a study will cause you
to make any changes in your life or your family’s
life you should really go back and check the
science.
No matter how reputable the source, it’s
always important to be aware of these issues,
whether you see it in Buzzfeed or the Economist.
Articles often gloss over all kinds of details. The kind of control group that was used, or whether
the study was done in mice or monkeys, all
of which can make a huge difference in how
strongly you can take the claims of the study.
And the bigger the life change you are thinking
about making, the more in depth your search
for information should be.
Adding a square or two of dark chocolate to your diet is not going to be a big deal.
Trying to cure cancer with high doses of Vitamin K just because some study found it kills
cancer cells in a dish that is.
So this doesn’t mean all the science you
read` about on Reddit or watch on your favorite
YouTube channel is wrong.
It just means that you need to use statistical
thinking to check which claims are reasonable
and which aren’t.
In order to help us remember some of the rules of thumb we talked about today, our writer
Chelsea came up with a limerick: And so without further ado.
Crash Course’s FIRST original limerick.
When a study reports correlations
Or has mice as its main population
The results it declares
May not be quite fair
So be careful about generalizations
Alright, let’s see you do better.
Thanks for watching. I'll see you next time.